Bem-vindo de volta à Computação Quântica na Prática. Este é o episódio 6. Hoje vamos nos concentrar em uma das minhas
aplicações favoritas dos computadores quânticos: simular a natureza. Neste episódio, vamos discutir as etapas necessárias
para fazer isso em qualquer tipo de problema de dinâmica quântica, que é o problema de encontrar como a descrição de um
sistema quântico muda com o tempo. Faremos isso primeiro em alto nível e depois analisaremos um exemplo específico,
detalhando-o: o experimento da IBM de 2023 que demonstrou a utilidade quântica. Como motivação rápida no
início: uma das histórias mais famosas que nós, do campo da computação quântica, contamos repetidamente
é a de Richard Feynman dando uma palestra no Caltech em 1959 e basicamente
motivando toda a área por décadas. A palestra se chamava "Há muito espaço lá embaixo" —
um título engraçado, mas a ideia básica era que ele afirmava que ainda havia tanta física rica a ser
descoberta no nível microscópico.
Agora, essa palestra específica não teve muita repercussão até os anos 80, quando a tecnologia havia se desenvolvido bastante. E Feynman
também esclareceu e refinou sua mensagem ao longo do tempo. Ele retornou ao Caltech nos anos 80 e apresentou outro artigo chamado
"Simulando a natureza com computadores", onde disse especificamente que queria falar sobre a possibilidade de haver
uma simulação exata — que o computador faria exatamente o mesmo que a natureza.
Essencialmente ser capaz de eliminar as aproximações grosseiras do que acontece na escala atômica e substituí-las por
computadores que entendem e aproveitam a física quântica para não apenas simular o que a natureza está fazendo, mas emulá-la.
Agora, lembre desta linha do tempo que mostrei em um episódio anterior. Em uma extremidade, tínhamos problemas fáceis de
resolver e que não vão exigir nenhum tipo de aceleração que o quântico poderia oferecer. Mas na outra extremidade, temos problemas que são
muito difíceis e precisam de máquinas quânticas tolerantes a falhas, que ainda não temos.
Felizmente, acreditamos que há bastante problemas de simulação que ficam aqui no meio, que é a região em que
podemos trabalhar atualmente. E há muitos motivos para ficar animado e intrigado com essa perspectiva, porque a
simulação da natureza é a base de muitas áreas de aplicação empolgantes — para citar algumas. Se pudéssemos simular melhor
a natureza, poderíamos acelerar a descoberta de novos materiais, criar melhores fármacos e medicamentos, ou
até explorar novas físicas subjacentes à física de partículas ou à cosmologia. Mas antes de você, eu ou qualquer pessoa tentar
aplicar a computação quântica a essas áreas empolgantes, por enquanto, será preciso entender as etapas básicas de um
fluxo de trabalho típico baseado em simulação.
Primeiro, você vai querer identificar um sistema quântico de interesse. Isso vai te informar sobre o Hamiltoniano que governa sua evolução
temporal e uma descrição significativa de suas propriedades iniciais, ou seu estado.
Em seguida, você precisará encontrar um método apropriado para implementar a evolução temporal desse estado. Com esses ingredientes
definidos, as próximas etapas envolvem a realização do experimento em si.
Geralmente isso envolve otimizar a implementação do quantum circuit do algoritmo de evolução temporal, executar o
circuit ou circuits no hardware quântico e pós-processar os resultados. Então podemos
nomear as etapas básicas envolvidas em um experimento de simulação da seguinte forma.
Identificar o Hamiltoniano do sistema, codificação do Hamiltoniano, preparação do estado, evolução do estado,
otimização do circuit, execução do circuit e pós-processamento.
Mas essas são etapas bastante detalhadas. Lembre que as quatro etapas do framework Qiskit patterns, que nos ajuda
a entender como implementar uma rotina no Qiskit, são: mapeamento, otimização do circuit, execução do circuit e
pós-processamento. Então essas quatro primeiras etapas aqui estão na verdade todas incluídas sob o guarda-chuva do mapeamento, e é por isso
que dedicamos um episódio inteiro a essa primeira etapa. Caso tenha perdido, por favor volte e assista o episódio anterior.
Agora vamos primeiro entender o que essas etapas significam antes de nos aprofundarmos em qualquer código. Então a primeira coisa básica que precisamos
fazer para realizar um experimento de simulação é identificar o Hamiltoniano que descreve o sistema. Às vezes —
na verdade, frequentemente — eles são bem conhecidos. Outras vezes, precisamos montá-los a partir da compreensão das contribuições de energia
dos pequenos subconjuntos do sistema completo, como aqui, onde hi é o Hamiltoniano atuando em um dos n subsistemas de h.
Também precisaremos verificar se o sistema consiste de férmions ou bósons, caso estejamos lidando com partículas elementares. Em seguida,
precisamos codificar o Hamiltoniano e traduzi-lo em termos que os computadores quânticos possam entender. Frequentemente,
esses Hamiltonianos serão compostos de partículas elementares ou sistemas de spin. Se estivéssemos simulando férmions ou bósons, precisaríamos
escolher uma transformação de codificação como a de Jordan-Wigner ou Bravyi-Kitaev. Essas transformações vão
nos dizer como traduzir a definição do Hamiltoniano escrito em termos dos componentes originais — os férmions ou
bósons — em operadores de Pauli, que são facilmente convertidos em gates em um computador quântico. Por exemplo, a transformação de Jordan-Wigner,
definida aqui, fornece um mapeamento de operadores fermiônicos para operadores de Pauli. Se já estivermos lidando
com sistemas de spin 1/2, que são muito comuns, estamos bem — exceto por possíveis coeficientes de normalização —
e não precisamos usar um esquema de codificação. Tendo codificado o Hamiltoniano desejado no conjunto de
gates do computador quântico, o próximo passo crucial é determinar o estado quântico inicial apropriado do qual iniciar nossa
simulação. Esse estado deve idealmente refletir algum significado físico ou configuração do
sistema em estudo. Por exemplo, se estamos interessados em explorar a energia do estado fundamental de uma molécula, poderíamos
começar com uma aproximação de Hartree-Fock ou outro estado facilmente preparável que tenha sobreposição significativa com o verdadeiro
estado fundamental. A escolha do estado fundamental inicial afeta não só a convergência de algoritmos variacionais
como VQE (o solver quântico variacional), mas também a precisão e eficiência da
evolução temporal ou da amostragem na estimativa de fase quântica. Em essência, o estado inicial serve como
ponto de partida para a computação, preparando o terreno para extrair observáveis úteis sobre o sistema quântico
que estamos modelando. A preparação de um estado arbitrário de n qubits, onde ci são os estados da base computacional e ai é
o coeficiente respectivo de cada estado, e a condição de normalização de 2 elevado a n menos um, pode geralmente ser abordada
inicializando o estado com o operador o — o estado inicial seria o estado padrão de todos os zeros, frequentemente escrito
assim, por simplificação. Em geral, isso requer um número exponencial de gates CNOT. Frequentemente,
estamos interessados em um estado inicial específico para o sistema, e sua preparação pode ser implementada com uma quantidade razoável
de recursos. Estados produto, por exemplo, nos quais os qubits não estão entrelaçados entre si, requerem apenas operações de single
qubit. Agora, ainda não tivemos a oportunidade de falar sobre a trotterização.
Embora alguns de vocês provavelmente já a conheçam. Em essência, a trotterização é um método para calcular exponenciação de matrizes que
usa aproximações para lidar com a natureza exponencial de operadores não comutativos. Quando dois operadores como HA
e HB não comutam, devemos usar um truque inteligente e aplicar alternadamente os exponenciais correspondentes de
e elevado a i HA e e elevado a i HB para n
vezes — os operadores de evolução alternados são aplicados. Não vou apresentar a prova aqui, mas vou compartilhar um link
para uma prova simples e elegante dessa afirmação na descrição. Mas a mensagem principal é esta: a evolução temporal é uma
parte importante do mapeamento também. A trotterização divide uma interação contínua em etapas discretas que podem
ser implementadas em um computador quântico. Após gerar o circuit trotterizado, finalmente concluímos a
etapa de mapeamento. Podemos agora avançar para a otimização do circuit.
Para fazer isso, eis o que precisa ser realizado: é necessário um layout de qubits que mapeie os qubits virtuais do
seu circuit para os físicos no hardware. Isso é necessário porque o hardware pode ter topologias específicas
que restringem a interação direta de qubits físicos. Enquanto a implementação de
um quantum circuit geralmente pressupõe a capacidade de qualquer qubit interagir com qualquer outro qubit. Em seguida, precisamos inserir
swap gates conforme necessário para rotear interações entre qubits que não estão conectados. Precisamos traduzir os
gates no nosso circuit para instruções de arquitetura de conjunto de instruções (ISA) que
possam ser executadas diretamente no hardware. Em seguida, precisamos realizar otimizações do circuit para minimizar a
profundidade e a contagem de gates. Essa etapa também pode ser realizada no circuit virtual — o circuit em que os qubits
ainda não foram mapeados para a topologia de um dispositivo. Mas lembre que muito disso é feito automaticamente para você no
Qiskit. Veremos exatamente como na próxima seção desta aula. Após a etapa de otimização, estamos prontos para executar
o circuit usando uma primitiva. Para a maioria dos experimentos de simulação, você está interessado em entender a mudança
de certas propriedades do sistema ao longo do tempo. Então é provável que você vá usar a primitiva estimator, pois ela
vai te permitir medir os valores esperados de observáveis correspondentes a propriedades específicas. Em seguida,
vamos configurar as melhores opções para o estimator, que pode adicionar técnicas de supressão e mitigação de erros. Por fim, executaremos o
experimento. A última etapa é pós-processar todos os dados. Isso extrai os valores esperados medidos ou, se
você estiver usando o sampler, a distribuição de probabilidade amostrada na base computacional. Se tudo o que você precisa
são os valores esperados dos observáveis de interesse, eles podem ser obtidos diretamente do estimator
em seus valores brutos e com mitigação de erros. Frequentemente, os valores esperados medidos serão então usados
em outros cálculos para outras quantidades de interesse que não requerem computação quântica e podem ser
calculadas em um computador clássico.
Agora vamos percorrer um exemplo real de um artigo muito influente que a IBM publicou há alguns anos, chamado
"Evidência da utilidade da computação quântica antes da tolerância a falhas". Esse artigo, que abreviamos carinhosamente como
o artigo da utilidade, tornou-se um artigo muito influente no campo da computação quântica quase imediatamente após sua publicação.
A tese geral do artigo é que um computador quântico ruidoso produziu resultados precisos, ou valores esperados,
usando 127 qubits e 2.880 gates, além das capacidades da computação de força
bruta, que é a simulação exata dos quantum circuits executados pelo hardware. Esse trabalho também foi
importante porque mostrou que um computador quântico poderia ser usado para verificar ou comparar resultados com outros
métodos clássicos aproximados para simulações quânticas, como algoritmos de redes tensoriais, onde a solução
não era conhecida a priori. O que também é bastante legal é que agora outras pessoas usando os sistemas IBM Quantum
na nuvem e o Qiskit podem duplicar e verificar esses resultados por conta própria.
Vou te mostrar como fazer exatamente isso. Então, para este exemplo, vamos ser um pouco mais específicos sobre as
etapas envolvidas no mapeamento deste problema para entradas que possam ser compreendidas por um dispositivo quântico. Neste caso,
vamos simular a dinâmica da magnetização total de um sistema de spins magnéticos dipolares em uma rede na
presença de um campo magnético externo. O sistema pode ser descrito por um modelo de Ising com um campo magnético transversal.
Modelamos isso com um quantum circuit parametrizado, onde os parâmetros correspondem ao valor ajustável da
interação spin-spin ou z e a intensidade do campo magnético X.
Esta série se chama Computação Quântica na Prática. Então vamos também discutir os procedimentos neste experimento
que vamos implementar para tornar os resultados os melhores possíveis. Em seguida, vamos discutir como remover
qubits ruins, ou qubits com baixas fidelidades de gate ou tempos de decoerência, que poderiam afetar drasticamente os
resultados experimentais. Esses qubits ruins podem ocorrer por calibração prévia ruim
ou por sistemas de dois níveis interagindo com o qubit. Remover alguns qubits da topologia nativa do hardware corresponde a
considerar um sistema em uma rede descrita pela topologia resultante. Também vamos discutir a criação do
quantum circuit parametrizado que implementa a evolução temporal do sistema via trotterização.
Para isso, será importante identificar as camadas de entrelaçamento, que são uma parte crítica para a principal técnica de
mitigação de erros que usaremos mais adiante. Então, neste ponto, quero garantir que você, a audiência, saiba
que pode acompanhar tudo o que estou prestes a discutir no tutorial vinculado abaixo e na plataforma IBM
Quantum Learning Platform. Nesse tutorial, o que você pode notar é que criamos uma série de funções auxiliares
no início do notebook que podemos chamar depois para facilitar nossa vida. Quero mencionar essas
funções agora, não porque faça parte do processo oficial ou formal, mas porque é o que os experimentalistas frequentemente fazem
na prática para os ajudar a executar esses tipos de experimentos. Isso também nos mostra como vamos decompor nosso
problema ainda mais. As funções que definimos no notebook são as seguintes: remover acoplamentos de qubits,
definir acoplamentos de qubits, construir os acoplamentos de camada, construir camadas de entrelaçamento e, por último, definir o
circuit trotterizado. Em seguida, vamos falar sobre acoplamentos de camada, que ajudam a definir como os qubits
interagem com seus vizinhos durante a simulação. Nossos dispositivos quânticos usam o que chamamos de layout
heavy-hexagonal — um padrão especial para conectar qubits. Nesse layout, podemos agrupar as conexões chamadas de arestas em três
conjuntos separados, onde nenhumas duas conexões no mesmo conjunto compartilham um qubit. Isso é
importante porque em um computador quântico real não podemos executar gates de dois qubits ao mesmo tempo se eles envolvem o
mesmo qubit. Cada qubit só pode estar envolvido em um gate por vez.
Dividindo todas as conexões em três camadas, podemos aplicar gates de dois qubits em todo o dispositivo em três
rodadas, garantindo que nenhum qubit seja usado em mais de um gate por camada.
Esses gates implementam a interação ZZ do modelo de Ising, e são repetidos a cada etapa da simulação, chamada de
passo de Trotter. O twirling modifica o ruído no dispositivo de forma que mesmo um modelo de ruído simples
seja provavelmente preciso. Isso também torna possível aprender com precisão o modelo de ruído e usar as informações obtidas
em técnicas de mitigação de erros.
Em seguida, temos que remover os qubits ruins da nossa lista possível de qubits físicos que podemos usar no
experimento. Como disse, um qubit pode ficar ruim por uma variedade de razões diferentes. Às vezes é apenas uma calibração
ruim, um erro simples que pode ser resolvido apenas calibrando novamente.
Às vezes é um pouco mais complicado e relacionado ao que chamamos de TLS, que é um defeito interfacial de dois níveis
que leva a flutuações de parâmetros e relaxação do qubit. Isso pode ser
resolvido aquecendo um pouco o sistema inteiro e depois resfriando-o novamente. Mas isso leva tempo e não é possível fazer
pela nuvem. Por enquanto, a coisa mais fácil a fazer é simplesmente excluí-los da nossa lista de qubits físicos
possíveis que vamos usar. Você pode identificar facilmente quais qubits não estão se comportando como esperado na plataforma IBM Quantum.
Você pode plotar as características dos qubits lá na plataforma ou baixá-las como CSV. Em seguida, crie uma lista de todos os
qubits que deseja excluir e simplesmente remova-os da lista de qubits físicos totais do dispositivo.
Certo. Agora vamos continuar com nossa etapa de mapeamento, gerando nosso circuit trotterizado. Como mostramos
anteriormente, a trotterização discretiza a evolução temporal em uma série de etapas e precisamos decidir quantas etapas.
Vamos escolher seis aqui. Mas em geral, a estratégia é equilibrar o que chamamos de erro de Trotter, que é um
erro de aproximação algorítmica, com o erro decorrente da decoerência. Mais etapas de Trotter reduzem o erro de aproximação,
mas requerem quantum circuits mais profundos, que sofrem mais ruído de decoerência. Vamos definir o
circuit em termos do parâmetro theta, que é a intensidade do campo magnético externo, os acoplamentos de camada e o
número de etapas e qubits e, claro, o backend do dispositivo. Por causa da
dependência da magnetização do sistema com a intensidade do campo magnético externo, é interessante
executar a simulação em vários valores da intensidade do campo magnético, que se traduzem em diferentes ângulos de RX na
rotação de RX no circuit. Agora, tendo gerado nosso circuit, avançamos para sua otimização.
O primeiro passo aqui é definir um gerenciador de passes. Lembre que no contexto do SDK do Qiskit, a transpilação se refere ao
processo de transformar um circuit de entrada em uma forma adequada para execução em um dispositivo quântico.
A transpilação geralmente ocorre em uma sequência de etapas chamadas passes do transpiler. Um gerenciador de passes é um objeto que
armazena uma lista de passes do transpiler e pode executá-los em um circuit. Crie um gerenciador de passes inicializando um objeto
gerenciador de passes com uma lista de passes do transpiler. No final, nosso gerenciador de passes
criará um circuit ISA — um circuit que deve ser escrito em termos da arquitetura de conjunto de instruções do backend,
que descreve o circuit e gates nativos ao backend, mas não possui as informações de temporização necessárias para executar o
circuit. Agora estamos prontos para executar nosso circuit, que é a etapa três dos Qiskit patterns. Como dito antes, usaremos definitivamente
o estimator como nossa primitiva de escolha para este experimento, já que queremos medir a
magnetização total do sistema, e estimar o valor esperado dos observáveis é para o que o estimator foi
projetado. Nessa etapa, também será crucial especificar nossas opções de mitigação de erros. Usaremos a extrapolação de
ruído zero para obter os melhores resultados possíveis. Em particular no tutorial, você verá que especificamos dois ou mais
valores de fator de ruído nos quais avaliar os modelos extrapolados e especificamos
a amplificação probabilística de erros como nossa opção de amplificação. Agora, a amplificação
probabilística de erros, ou PEA, foi realmente a técnica de mitigação de erros de escolha aqui, porque escala muito
melhor do que as outras opções. E é isso que importa quando trabalhamos no nível de 100 qubits ou mais.
Por último, mas não menos importante, execute o experimento — vai levar algum tempo para ser concluído, mas por enquanto vamos referenciar os dados
armazenados do tutorial. Vamos examinar os metadados prestando atenção especial aos gates em camadas e
às camadas mitigadas, pois estamos prestes a usá-las para remover vários erros dos nossos dados brutos. Estamos quase prontos
para plotar nossos resultados finais. Mas antes disso, vamos rapidamente adicionar um interlúdio sobre o que exatamente é a extrapolação de
ruído zero, ou ZNE. Cobrimos brevemente em episódios anteriores, mas para revisar: a extrapolação de ruído zero
é uma técnica de mitigação de erros que remove os efeitos de um ruído desconhecido durante a execução do circuit, que pode ser
escalonado de uma forma conhecida. Ela pressupõe que os valores esperados escalam com o ruído por uma função conhecida mostrada aqui, onde os
parâmetros lambda especificam a intensidade do ruído e podem ser amplificados. Podemos implementar a ZNE com as seguintes etapas.
Primeiro, amplificar o ruído do circuit para vários fatores de ruído: lambda 1, lambda 2,
lambda 3, e assim por diante. Executar cada circuit com ruído amplificado para medir
o valor esperado a de lambda 1, a de lambda 2, e assim por diante. E então extrapolar de volta para o limite de
ruído zero, o valor esperado a de zero.
O principal desafio em implementar com sucesso a ZNE é ter um modelo preciso para o ruído no valor esperado
e amplificar o ruído de uma forma conhecida.
Há três maneiras comuns de implementar a amplificação de erros para a ZNE: escalar a duração do pulso via calibração,
repetir gates em ciclos de identidade e adicionar ruído via amostragem de canais de Pauli.
Chamamos este último de PEA. A amplificação probabilística de erros é a melhor escolha aqui porque o alongamento de pulso é muito
computacionalmente custoso. O folding de gates carece de garantias teóricas para preservar o bias de ruído. Mas a PEA pode ser
aplicada a qualquer circuit que possa ser executado com fatores de ruído nativos, mas requer aprender o modelo de ruído. A PEA pressupõe
o mesmo modelo de ruído baseado em camadas do que o cancelamento probabilístico de erros.
No entanto, evita a sobrecarga de amostragem que escala exponencialmente com o ruído do circuit. Para aprender o modelo de ruído,
devemos primeiro identificar as camadas únicas de operações de dois qubits no circuit.
Para cada camada, aplicar twirling de Pauli nos gates de dois qubits para garantir que o ruído seja bem descrito por um modelo de ruído de damping.
Repetir pares de identidade de camadas em profundidade variável e, por fim, ajustar uma fidelidade ou um erro para cada canal de ruído.
E claro, embora eu recomende entender esse método até certo ponto, fazê-lo manualmente no Qiskit é
muito mais simples, como mostrado no tutorial. Agora, finalmente, vamos dar uma olhada nos dados plotados. A linha
tracejada cinza mostra os resultados exatos obtidos com métodos clássicos aproximados, com erro de aproximação
convergindo para um limiar baixo. Como você pode ver, os dados brutos para os diferentes fatores de ruído que escolhemos no
início estão bem distantes dessa linha tracejada. A linha azul sólida mostra os dados levando em conta nosso processamento
ZNE. E dá pra ver de cara que está muito mais próxima dos resultados exatos.
Em resumo, os valores ruidosos mostram alta desvio dos valores exatos.
Os valores mitigados estão próximos dos valores exatos, demonstrando a utilidade da técnica de mitigação baseada em PEA.
E isso essencialmente conclui este episódio. Para resumir rapidamente o que aprendemos: a simulação quântica é uma
das áreas de aplicação mais promissoras no curto a médio prazo.
Ela tem aplicações de amplo alcance, desde farmacêuticos até física de alta energia,
ciência de materiais e muito mais. O artigo da utilidade da IBM publicado em 2023 apontou
o caminho para o uso de computadores quânticos para descoberta científica. E trabalhamos com o
tutorial associado ao artigo em profundidade. As etapas para trabalhar em um problema de simulação do início ao
fim são relativamente diretas, especialmente depois que você pega o jeito. E minha esperança é que você
possa daqui em diante usar este vídeo e o tutorial como guia para ainda mais problemas de simulação no futuro.
Obrigada por assistir e até a próxima vez na Computação Quântica na Prática.